let's go next to our caller from the
6:00 to 3:00 area code who is calling
today from 6:00 to 3:00
can you uh can you hear me David you
know I can who's this oh my gosh this is
amazing
hey David this is Matthew I've been I've
been watching you and you're on the
drunken peasants actually like forever
ago yeah I don't even know yeah I did
yeah it's been a while I actually was on
a trip going to Europe to be with my dad
for a while
that's called tried calling over there
but now that I'm back in the US my u.s.
number got it actually went through but
I'll stop talking about all that kind of
stuff actually it's not really a
question but it's more of like getting
your opinion if you think there's even
feasible or not because basically well
let me put it in this context first
because I have like two like fundamental
sets of beliefs I guess that I've
incorporated into what I'm about to try
to explain and most you are basically
good ideas that help people are good
ideas like regardless of their origin or
where they come from like if you can
implement them successfully and it's
proven to have results then you know
they obviously you know they should be
implemented and the other one excuse me
is that if corporations do not exist for
the people that by proxy turned out the
proxy but a by default they directly are
like in existence against us because
they're not seeing us as like a UH
what's it called like a reliable they're
like a consumer base that they were kids
like the best product possible I mean
how many stories are we gonna see where
corporations have been cutting costs
they've been trying to get I think I got
a so given that that's the context
Matthew what what were you going to ask
my opinion about yeah sorry I just about
trying to waste time but basically uh do
you think that it would be feasible
after implementing a policy maybe not a
see but uh some kind of regulation to
where not only the workers for these
companies are getting paid like a
minimum wage that's enough to where they
could actually go out and buy goods and
services in this capitalistic society
that we're all a part of that will
therefore increase demand for certain
products have been supply if they can do
that
but also set maximum wages for
themselves at the highest levels about
all the other excess what they call
profits all the you know things at the
end of the year all that should be put
back into the business basically to
ensure quality like quality control and
you know making sure that they have the
best product possible because like I
said before if a company is existing for
the people to bear existing against us
just to exploit us basically so
basically that's just it's mandating
companies be nonprofits or coops I mean
a non-profit at the end of the year you
know the money gets gets it stays in the
organization and that's a very
particular type of alignment you know as
far as maximum wages I'm not sure the
the legal infrastructure that would be
very very would be complicated it would
be very hard to actually implement and I
think there would be massive massive
opposition I think there's a lot of
lower hanging fruit that could be done
first in terms of democratizing the
workplace including putting workers on
boards of directors having work or
representation on board of directors and
there's a lot of other things that that
would be much simpler to do
legislatively and legally that I would
look at first yeah of course you know
I'm not really uh I mean I do spend
quite a bit of time thinking about these
topics but obviously like this is your
you know your job and like I said I've
been watching here I'm a drunken
peasants a while ago right I've just
been sitting on this for a while and I
thought well farmer to get anybody's
opinion let me try to get David Pakman I
appreciate you think so Miley I I'm
flattered I'm glad that you were able to
get on and I do hope to hear from you
again